many families that lost loved ones to
covet 19 say they are just
frustrated that the president is still
downplaying the threat after his
hospital stay
amanda klutz for instance wife of
broadway star nick cordero
who died from the coronavirus recorded
an emotional response after the
president's statement on monday night
don't let it dominate you
don't be afraid of it let it dominate
your life
no one's letting it nick didn't let it
it wasn't a choice
have some empathy to the people who are
suffering and grieving
oh man more than 3 100 americans have
died of covid
since mr trump revealed his positive
test five days ago our lead national
correspondent david begnell spoke to
others who say
they too are hurt by the president's
comments
i just felt really disrespected and
unheard this is kara goucher
a two-time u.s olympian and silver
medal-winning long-distance runner
her grandfather 96-year-old calvin
hayworth died yesterday due to
complications from the coronavirus
when we when we spoke to her earlier in
the day she told us that she just could
not believe what the president was
saying about covid19
i'm glad that he was treated and that he
is beating cobit but for so
many people hundreds of thousands of
people in this country that's not the
case
and the pain is very very real the tone
from the top matters
karen aguirre told us it was the
president's behavior that upset her
she lost her cousin 65 year old sandy
melgar
and sandy's 66 year old husband renee to
the virus last month
they died three days apart when i saw
him get in the car
with the secret service agents and drive
around
and wave to everybody and i thought the
people in the car have families
the people who tend to him they have
families
and now they're exposed to a virus
they're going to take home with them
as the president continues to downplay
the virus
goucher is asking president trump for
more compassion
i really was thinking today watching my
grandfather struggle with
every breath of his being his life is
worthy
he is a world war ii veteran he deserves
to die with dignity
and with respect and with his family
surrounding him
and if we had all worn our masks and if
we had all social distanced
we would be able to hug him and tell him
what we feel and hold his hand and it's
devastating to lose him
kara was especially close to her
grandfather
he helped to raise her and her sisters
after kara's dad died
killed by a drunk driver when carol was
just four years old
both of the women you just heard from
both of them went out of their way to
say we are glad the president is
recovering
and we want him to do well but gail
cara in particularly said david for
those of us who are suffering
some empathy goes a long way boy david
thank you very much it's so important to
hear those voices anthony it reminds me
of the pieces you do so beautifully
about the lives that have been lost and
a reminder that these are real people
behind these numbers
and that it affects the old the young
every income
bracket every race creed color you know
gail it's just
it's 200 and almost what's like 210 210.
i thought amanda made a good point where
she said we didn't let it dominate our
lives
happened to us it destroyed our lives
there's nothing we couldn't do that
boy ahead it's one of those stories you
look at the story and all you can do is
just go
um